allez allez ouais super Teddy oui
bonsoir nos amis les bêtes c'est sacré
en France on les aime on les bisonne et
écoutez bien il y a plus de chiens de
chats et de poissons que d'être humain
en France suivez-moi je vous emmène au
parc allez on y va t'aider en retard
vêtue de noir bandana vert sur la tête
l'homme tient dans sa main un couteau il
est 9h45 il vient d'attaquer à l'arme
blanche 4 enfants en bas âge dans l'air
de jeu du Pâquier au bord du lac
d'Annecy deux d'entre eux sont en
urgence absolue dans sa fuite la
saillance en prend à un vieil homme lui
à scène plusieurs coups de couteau avant
d'être neutralisé par les policiers qui
ont tout vert le feu vous vous montrez
indignes de votre fonction
idées vous nous avez empêché de voter
vous avez aux éleveurs mais vous êtes
devenus complètement fou nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui à une rupture
démocratique majeure et vous en êtes
madame la Présidente la responsable il
arrive vers moi donc je m'écarte un peu
et
je m'écarte et je vois qu'ils font tout
droit sur des papiers et mamie
et là et là il attaque il attaque le
papy il le poigna une fois les flics et
derrière lui arrive pas à l'attraper
qu'une fois deux fois et là il commence
à tirer donc il tire devant moi
sur la personne
donc il tombe à terre et mais bon le
papy était déjà touché je vous remercie
madame la Présidente d'avoir pris les
devants la première ministre se rend sur
les lieux il y a de très jeunes enfants
en bas âge qui sont en état d'urgence
absolue et je vous invite à respecter le
minutes de silence pour eux pour leur
famille je vous remercie
ses actes se multiplient se répètent
donc j'appelle à une réaction
extrêmement forte à une réaction de tous
ceux qui ne veulent pas que notre
civilisation soit détruite c'est plutôt
bourratif
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si on prend comme indicateur les
émissions de CO2 émises par habitant là
ce sont bien les pays du Golfe qui se
classent en tête avec ces chiffres à
hallucinants il faut le dire en tête
donc le Qatar avec 35,6 tonnes de CO2
par habitant pardon émise en 2021 suivi
par Bahreïn par le Koweït les ebirats
Arabes Unis 21 tonnes par habitant à
titre de comparaison en France un
habitant aimé 4,7 tonnes de CO2 et un
Américain 14
commencé comme ça je vais vous taper
respirer de ouf vous allez pas rire
parce que ça vous pose sur la
respiration
c'est trop gêné parce que j'ai pas envie
que les esprits viennent me hanter j'ai
pas envie de finir la nuit dévorée par
un animal j'en ai aucune idée
respire l'air le plus toxique le plus
empoisonné de la planète c'est le taux
d'asthmatique le plus élevé une étude de
la revue Nature climat change à révélé
il y a quelques temps qu'en 2100 pour un
être humain le simple fait d'être à
l'extérieur dans le golfe Persique
pourrait être mortel tout ça est assez
réjouissant les images du jour sont
encore plus impressionnantes la Statue
de la Liberté les gratte-ciels sont
plongées dans un brouillard orange des
vols ont dû être annulés les feux
continuent de progresser dans la
province de Québec aucune pluie
importante n'est prévue avant lundi soir
apparemment quasiment répété
c'était donc un sourire de façade lors
du dernier match de Ligue 1 Lionel Messi
le sait probablement déjà il va signer
pour l’intermiami raison invoquée par le
Champion du Monde son mal-être depuis
qu'il est au PSG ce sont deux années
pendant lesquelles je n'ai pas été
heureux et je n'ai pas profité et cela
affecté ma vie de famille
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle j'ai
pris cette décision
pour me reconnecter entre guillemets
avec ma famille avec mes enfants et pour
profiter du quotidien Lionel Messi
disposait de plusieurs choix quant à son
avenir celui du coeur avec son ancien
club le Barça celui du portefeuille avec
l'Arabie Saoudite qui lui offrait 400
millions d'euros par saison avec l'Inter
Miami dont les modalités de son futur
contrat n'ont pas été totalement révélés
il concilie un peu les deux et la raison
voulait un son de déconnexion de ce
qu'est le monde du football
on écouterait Lionel Messi ces gens
n'ont pas le droit de se plaindre
cette émission française préférée
[Rires]
mais bien sûr comment pourriez-vous ne
pas être mon émission favorite on a
passé tellement bons moments ensemble ce
que j'ai en coulisses c'est la plus
belle performance que j'ai donné chez
vous il y a même un ministère de alors
je sais plus mais de la voiture un
ministère de la masturbation en
Australie non mais dans une des communes
d'Australie qui a dit que allez-y et
vous risquez rien du tout et surtout
n'ayez pas honte c'est pas grave dans
votre coin n'imposez pas
c'est à dire que jamais vous ne vous
êtes senti aussi bien et jamais le son
du groupe n'a été aussi bon que lorsque
vous étiez sur le plateau de c'est à
VOUS absolument exact et bien ne nous
remercions pas j'arrête c'est un plaisir
ces internautes ont filmé un ours noir
se promenant tranquillement dans leur
jardin d'acheville une ville américaine
connue pour son importante population de
plantesigrade cette vidéo a été vu des
milliers de fois et pour cause la balade
zen de l'ours au soleil
s'est transformée en panique pour
l'animal effrayé par le père de famille
camouflé en grizzly un déguisement au
final pas si bête